JOE KREITZ: One of the greatest
bottlenecks in the area of gene
therapy is delivery.
If you can't deliver
a therapeutic payload
into a diseased
cell, you sort of
have no hope of curing that
cell in any meaningful way.
And so in attempting
to solve this problem,
we are highly
inspired by viruses,
which, through the
process of evolution,
have developed elegant
methods by which
to infiltrate host cells.
And one method used by a
certain class of viruses
that infect bacteria are called
bacteriophages, and here's
a little bacteriophage virus.
And so these phages utilize this
really elegant macromolecular
syringe device.
And here's this kind of syringe
structure beneath the capsid
of the virus.
And they use these syringes
to sort of directly
puncture their host membranes.
And this device is known as a
contractil injection system,
this kind of syringe structure.
In a manner similar to
the action of a virus
injecting its genome
into a host cell,
we are developing
contractile injection systems
capable of injecting
therapeutic proteins directly
into human cells.
And through this
project, we first
successfully purified a novel
contractile injection system
from a laboratory
organism in E. coli.
We next show that
the system is capable
injecting large protein cargos
into cultured eukaryotic cells.
Finally, we're
currently reprogramming
the system for injection
against cultured human cells
with the ultimate
intention of developing
safe and specific
therapeutic delivery
devices with these
contracted injection systems
to enable the next
generation of gene therapy.